اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز اهلا بكم استشهاد
الصحفيين حمزه الدحدوح نجل الزميل وائل
الدحدوح ومصطفى ثريا في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف سياره كانت تقل صحفيين شمال رفح
ليرتفع بذلك عدد الصحفيين الذين استهدفوا
بنيران الاحتلال في القطاع الى
199 منذ بدء
الحرب عشرات الشهداء في قصف اسرا
على مناطق متفرقه في القطاع والدفاع
المدني قال ان عدد المفقودين تجاوز 8 الاف
واعلن تعطل 70% من قدراته التشغيليه بسبب
نقص
الوقود كتائب القسام تعلن استهداف القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
متزامنه من جهته اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
مقتل نائب قائد وحده التدريب في لواء
ناحل مطالبات لجانس بالاستقاله لاسقاط
حكومه الطوارئ الاسرائيليه ونحو 170 قائدا
عسكريا اسرائيليا سابقا يتحدثون عن حرب
داخل الحكومه ضد رئيس الاركان في حين قال
نتنياهو ان الحرب ستتواصل حتى اتمام
المهمه مطالبا بوضع الخلافات جانبا وتوحيد
الصفوف وفي الضفه الغربيه استشهد ثمانيه
فلسطينيين برصاص الاحتلال بينهم سبعه في
جنين كما قتلت جنديه اسرائيليه واصيب
اربعه في اشتباكات مع مسلحين فلسطينيين من
جهتها اعلنت كتيبه جنين تفجير عبوات ناسفه
في قوات الاحتلال اثناء توغلها في المخيم
الى
اللقاء